so i'm here in the house
also known as the hotbox
in osterpanka and
this family
is amazing like they can
dig a well make absolutely anything from
nothing survive off the land the list
goes on and on right but there's one
thing
that
i don't understand at all
and that is uh ventilation of the house
we've been keeping the windows closed at
night when it's cooler out and the house
is warmer inside so i made up this
little diagram 40 celsius outside
30 celsius inside
we keep the windows closed
when it's 20 outside and 30 inside we
open the windows
put the fan on
when it's the next morning
and it's 20 outside and 20 inside
we um
close the windows again so i bought a
couple fans too
to help out this process because there's
absolutely like no ventilation in the
house
yet yeah wow she's used to it
[Music]
[Applause]
and the fans have found
a home near the
the one window that well there's a
couple of them but the window that
doesn't open the biggest
mystery so far
[Music]
i believe
got up early this morning did the usual
prayed with the family
ate breakfast and then
valeria and i
went out to
a few people's homes and gave them rice
i don't know where valetti gets this
rice i think he must get it through the
church or something because we have like
a lot of rice
cheese
but the thing is we don't eat it i think
we've only eaten it like once and they
like it but she just gives it out
so we walked around to different
people's homes and
obviously people that needed rice or any
food
we just gave rice
[Music]
it's very simple very humbling this man
despite losing what he's lost and not
having much economically still gives
former gulpnic street fighter
alcoholic
drug addict
he told me he's done
pretty much everything and he was he was
shooting up a lot
um i don't think it was heroin i think
they
they use something different here i'm
not sure what it is but it's something
like heroin he shows
ukrainians and everyone else the world
you can turn it around
lesson number
i don't know
536 of this trip
it's really humbling
to uh watch what this man does and how
he works and
his constant giving is constant helping
i want to talk about anna
i've never seen anything quite like her
she does absolutely everything she knows
exactly what she's doing there's no
hesitation she cooks she takes care of
these kids amazingly well she's a
beautiful mother always positive always
laughing never complaining
actually early this morning we went out
to
to a school
and helped kids
with toys
it's pretty sad actually there's this
like these broken toys and we showed up
with super glue and a few things and
she's just cool she's one of the coolest
people i know
she plays the piano she's she can paint
she can sing i love this woman on
[Music]
here we are this morning digging the
well
there's our man
the one and only
max
a special case and then look how deep we
are now
getting really far in there
[Music]
so the animal slaughterings are
not my favorite
part out here
you know bloody cut the head off
and then he grabs it by the feet and
lets the blood
drain out of it
but the wings are still flapping
so it's sort of a twisted sight
[Laughter]
and then it went right into a hot bucket
of water anna had the bucket of water
and
they defathered it
and they skinned it and we were cooking
the thing like within an hour
or eating within an hour
they're super connected like i said
they're super connected with their food
so i get it it's cool that they're doing
it that way
i mean it's
it's how they live the goose
slaughtering
not nearly as bad as the goat
thick-skinned looking dude he came with
a knife
he's like i guess the guy in town who if
you want to go butchered he's the guy to
come over and do it he normally takes 50
grievna which is like two dollars
let it give him a hundred grifna so four
dollars to do all that work
and it wasn't any sort of quick death i
mean the thing was
struggling for a long time
i'm not gonna lie that wasn't the most
enjoyable experience to uh watch that
thing get slaughtered but
hey it's how it happens here well
they're close to their food they're
super
in touch with what they're eating so
nothing against it i'm just gonna say
it's like not the most enjoyable
experience to
to witness
just being that up close and personal to
the process makes it
a little less attractive eating meat
which i was eating at like an hour after
i was eating the kidneys in the heart
and everything and
whatever other organs that were on my
plate
[Laughter]
and
it's good protein
i was happy to get the protein to be
honest i felt really good afterwards
so velode is going uh deep on the uh
the goat's head
and i'm just gonna uh
get the amateur room and have some eggs
this evening instead
the tongue was good though the tongue is
actually quite tasty
ah
yeah they're really close to their food
everything's up close and personal it's
not done in some factory it's not done
it's a mysterious way it's it's done by
their own hands
by their animals that they fed the food
they know
it's more real
but i don't want to do it it's not my
thing
[Laughter]
so
[Music]
foreign
11.
[Music]
that's that story like all these days
i'm pretty dead at the end so
until next time
sayonara
[Music]
you